good morning I saved you the best part
drunk you if I get fired tomorrow it's
because I won inappropriately touched my
boss - made him buy me a Big Mac three
through my Big Mac at him for threw a
hot sell out his car window please make
sure I'm up at 10:30 if I still have a
job I have to work at 11:00 a.m. guys my
bad a Clinton want to wake up are you
guys please don't kill me Oh today's eye
glasses under bed no questions I don't
have time for your [ __ ] sober dawn good
morning eat a bag of dicks reminder
laundry [ __ ] coke beer hummus G
bread yeah so where you can figure this
out lost Keys law where's Angela please
make waffles love John I wanna sex you
up six in a thong I drink your Arnold
Palmer sorry here's a dollar - yeah -
duvet covers and sheets are clean fits
in the job make picture of Nicolas Cage
[ __ ] the Declaration from both sides
Ross
instead of being a dick and hiding your
keys phone wallet I made you your lunch
for tomorrow suck it drunk Ross skull
with six tentacles look it up I'm candy
the guy on the couch I did your dishes
and put them away the best I could also
I cleaned the stove and took out the
trash PS I drew you guys a picture